welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and black panther we're kind of
forever changes the game in the MCU in
separate ways Chief among them being a
second vibradian meteorite that crashed
into Earth leading to the undersea
Kingdom of talocon so the previously
singular what if thought experiment that
gave us wakanda now looks less like a
happenstance occurrence and more part of
a pattern so who keeps throwing vibrate
him at her Galactus are these your
spitballs no but seriously where in the
cosmos does vibranium come from how can
it be as supposedly rare as it is while
resulting in the astronomically
improbable scenario of two meteorites of
it colliding with the same planet and if
the answer to that question is someone
intentionally sent them here could the
origin of vibranium tell us something
about the celestials and the Eternal War
over their plan for mankind in wakan
Forever namora introduces himself to
Ramona and shuri saying that his mother
told him stories about wakanda but they
didn't know who he was meaning that
despite what kind of pre-dating telecon
by thousands of years by the way wakanda
was founded in 10 000 BC talocon was
founded in the 1570s 80 telecon's
location under the ocean kept it a
secret while wakanda's borders with
other African nations forced it out in
the open however both kingdoms had their
roots and vibranium meteorites that
struck Earth millions of years prior the
meteorite that hit wakanda struck in
what was believed to be 2.5 Million
Years BC which would be eons before
human civilization was able to develop
that was with the Sumerians around 5000
BC who according to MCU history met the
eternals five thousand years after
bashenga founded wakanda in 10 000 BC
but wakanda forever establishes that
there was a second vibranium meteorite
that struck somewhere in the water on
Earth after anamora's introduction Okoye
Ramona and shuri meet in the lab
becausee says I'm still struggling to
believe that vibranium exists outside of
wakanda sure he explains perhaps there
was more than one meteorite our planet
is covered in mostly water so it's
reasonable that the other one just
landed there Ramona says this changes
everything we know Okoye says the great
Mound all of the Legends and fables
these stories are seared in my mind
injury equips must be painful because
shuri starts his movie as a skeptic with
limited belief in wakanda mythology but
no more later confirms shuri's Theory
saying that his ancestors Mayans in the
year 1571 were led by their deity shot
through a water hole in the jungle on
the Yucatan Peninsula where this
ancestor found an aquatic version of the
heart-shaped herb this is the same water
role that Nakia uses to access nemour's
glowworm cave and that cave leads to the
jet stream current Waypoint to talukan
placing telecon in the vibranium-rich
ocean floor somewhere off the coast of
the Yucatan Peninsula in the Gulf of
Mexico and in real world Earth's
geological history the Yucatan Peninsula
in the Gulf of Mexico are the site of
the shiksha lube crater impact this was
the asteroid that struck Earth 66
million years ago reshaped the planet
into the Cretaceous Period and killed
the dinosaurs so the MCU may be
suggesting that this historic asteroid
also carried with it vibranium and this
would not be the first time Marvel
Studios touched upon the Chic shaloob
impact event in the eternals film it was
heavily implied that the arrival of the
seed of the celestial Tiamat was what
created that impact every million years
new celestials must be born I plant
Celestial seeds into host planets Across
the Universe the planet Earth was chosen
to host the celestial team now look
closely at that Shockwave it clears the
clouds in the sky forms a massive impact
blast on the surface extremely likely
that this is what formed the Sheikh
salute crater and if you look even more
closely at this eternal symmetry you can
follow the seed as it Burrows down into
the Earth's core and as it breaks
through the ground glowing pieces of it
break off and stay lodged in the Earth
at various levels we could be looking at
the same vibranium that namura and his
people used to build talukan now I'm not
making this [ __ ] up this idea of
vibranium being brought to Earth by
celestials does have basis in the Marvel
Comics the Earth X Series established
that vibranium was implanted on planets
to create a shell for celestials that
use these planets to gestate these
Comics state that the origin of
vibranium is intertwined with celestials
elsewhere in the Marvel Comics
vibranium's origin was established as
certainly extraterrestrial but otherwise
unknown there have been instances of
Antarctic vibranium on earth and the
Savage lands and Carol Danvers found
vibranium on the planet torpa when the
spartac's Empire mines the planet for
vibranium torfa did appear in the 2019
Captain Marvel film but torpo was never
definitively established as vibranium's
origin per se now it can be hard to
watch actors and not immediately think
hey I'd like to have gorgeous skin and
hair just like they do well with geology
you can geology is a fourth time
award-winning personalized skincare
company recognizing Men's Health Esquire
and asked men grooming Awards with over
6 000 5 Star reviews and they've
recently expanded to offer products for
pretty much whatever you need like if
you need Hair Care use geology's co-wash
it's a specially formulated cream
cleanser that removes buildup and
cleanses the hair without the big lather
or harsh ingredients of typical shampoo
and for the rest of your shower routine
you can use their body washes they're
free of harsh ingredients smell great
and are refillable and for after the
shower protect your skin from
environmental stressors with vitamin C
plus e feralic serums keep your skin
looking young and healthy and then a bit
of the dermatologist tested aluminum
free deodorant that quite honestly
smells great right now for limited time
geology is hooking our audience up with
an absolutely insane offer if you use
the code new rockstars they will give
you an additional 70 off their
award-winning skincare trial set this
discount stacks on top of their current
sale prices and there's also an
additional bonus offer on one of their
brand new skin hair and body products of
your choice when you add it to your
trial with the holidays right around the
corner geology has you covered check out
their awesome gift sets featuring all of
your favorite geology products to get
started just click the link in the
description take a 30 second diagnostic
quiz and their team of dermatologists
will design a personalized routine just
for you that ships directly to your door
but given vibranium's Godly status I
would not be surprised if Marvel Studios
established it as a gift from the
celestials and the studio keeps hinting
at a shared ancestry between wakanda
forever and eternals both titles were
championed specifically by executive
Nate Moore who made a point to mention
that what kind of forever takes place
after eternals in the MCU timeline what
kind of forever director Ryan cooglers
told comicbook.com that people believe
that earthquakes under the ocean line in
Avengers end game was a non-do eternals
and and umbaka uses specific words to
warn the others about killing Amore they
called him
the feather serpent God killing him will
risk Eternal War
Eternal War now if we are saying that
the celestial team at brat talukoneal
vibranium to earth does that mean
there's a second Celestial beneath Mount
bashinga and I don't know I think the
vibranium meteorite that poor Mount
bashango was sent to Earth as a
correction to place Godly medal on Earth
so that mankind could use it to advance
on its own perhaps is that they'll save
to aeroshim's plan to use eternals to
kill deviants and allow intelligent life
to thrive the Tiamat that wakanda
meteorite could have been another way to
expedite human advancement alternatively
the wakandan vibranium could have been
sent by another Celestial or Cosmic
entity who was sympathetic to humankind
one who wanted to give the Terence a way
to protect themselves with technology of
their own to fight back against
celestials and arguably we have already
been seeing that process this whole time
the wakandans gave Earth Black Panther
and wakandan vibranium led to Captain
America's shield and and vision and Sam
Wilson's latest suit and other weapons
probably soon to be explored in armor
Wars I mean if you consider Cap's Shield
to be the origin of the Avengers
Initiative really the whole MCU wouldn't
exist without vibranium this is what I
think the real Eternal war is Terence
like the Titan Prometheus using the
weapon of the Gods to fight the gods a
proxy war where a cosmic entity gave us
underdogs enough Weaponry to overthrow
our Lords so who was that sympathetic
benefactor well we did meet some
suspects in Thor love and thunder in
that Cosmic entity chamber at the center
of the universe there was eternity who
transformed into Cosmic entity love and
the wakanda meteorite that delivered
vibranium to Earth was arguably an act
of Love Now that chamber also contained
the celestial one above all who I
believe is the leader of the celestials
part of the old guard of the celestial
perhaps the first host of them maybe an
elder among the celestials who wanted to
overrule the rash actions of the next
generation of them the vibranium could
have been an interference by The Watcher
or some mandated child support by The
Living Tribunal and I love the idea that
the vibranium meteorite that struck
wakanda could have been drawn into Earth
by baby intimate himself remember in the
2018 black panther prologue in jobu
calls vibranium quote the strongest
substance in the universe doesn't it
make sense for Celestial armor to be
made out of that in the MCU let me know
if you think Celestial sent vibranium to
Earth and you can follow me on Tick Tock
Instagram and Twitter at EA boss follow
new Rockstar subscribe to new Rockstar
some more analysis of everything you
love thanks for watching bye
[Music]